I like things that are different if you
do what everybody expects you're just
doing the ordinary but if you surprise
people that's fun
hey Fandango fence this is Stanley
saying egg so forth
[Music]
the first time I met Robert Downey jr. I
remember was at the premiere of the
movie and he came over to me and he was
so grateful for him having government
role for me having created that
character he sort of knelt down in front
of me and if it was a touching scene I
was I was very touched by it if I want
there to be a star in my own film and
pitch it to Kevin Smith I'm not quite
sure who the characters would be at the
moment because I you're catching me cold
with this but I'd wanted to have humor
I'd wanted to have characters that were
bigger than life who were able to do
things that the average man can't do I'd
like it to have tremendous drama and as
I say humor I think the combination of
the two are an unbeatable combination
well it was such a pleasure for me to
meet a guy who not only knows drama and
action and adventure and superhero stuff
but who also had a great sense of humor
and I figured you put all those
abilities together and well you saw what
we got guardians of the galaxy it was a
great movie if I am like if I'm the six
infinities oh I don't know about it
nobody has told me that and I'll have to
whittle the movie and find out what kind
of a cameo they'd given me the cameo may
give it all away I don't know but it's
nice if people wonder about these things
and that's what's Marvel does so well I
think they put things out there that are
almost teasers and the fans say wow
how's that gonna turn out I wonder what
that means
how will that affect is this elicit so
as you can probably tell I very much
like the way Marvel operates what they
do and how they do it I'm very pleased
with all of it we have a great actor
playing the role
we have a great theme that I don't think
there has ever been a character like the
Black Panther with his background with
his abilities with his whole situation
and he's unique he's different hope I'm
not exaggerating this but I think the
Black Panther is going to be a major it
you know why I did Captain Marvel
because there was a character and it was
owned by Fawcett meant by Disney there
was fighting over it and we couldn't use
the name but I wanted my name was Marvel
Comics and I wanted something with the
word Marvel in it and we finally decided
we made her a female I don't know I just
decided to make her a female I can't
remember why I thought I like things
that are different if you do what
everybody expects you're just doing the
ordinary but if you surprise people
that's fun and I think people were
surprised to see that our Captain Marvel
was a female so that was fun for me
actually all our characters whether male
or female should serve as role models
for the readers above and beyond the
adventure and all the super stuff they
should serve as role models in the sense
that they always try to help other
people and they always try to do the
right thing when I see the characters
that I helped to create on the screen I
don't really think of them as my
characters I I really sit in the theater
and I watch them the way every member of
the audience watches them and at the end
of the movie I usually say damn that was
good
I'm so glad and I do remember maybe oh
they had a scene in there that was based
on something I had written that was
great I I got a kick out of
but I don't really think of the
characters as my characters because I
came up with the basic idea but I worked
with artists directors added so much to
the characters and their direction the
actors who brought so much it isn't a
one-man field it is so many people
contributed I'm just happy that I've had
a hand in all of this and I'm happy that
even after all these years someone
bothers to interview me about it I'm
really very flattered
[Music]
I'm probably my own biggest fan but as
always tell people who asked me for tips
on writing I think what you have to do
you have to write to please yourself I
never would write anything where I say
this will be good for people who are 30
years old or this will be good for
people in their teens or all I ever
think of is what would I want to read
what characters would interest me and
I'm not that different from millions of
other people if there's something I
would like to read there must be other
people who'd like to read the same thing
a hundred years from now if somebody
should bring up my name it it would
still be around in a hundred years it
would be nice if people say jeez like I
thought he was a good writer his stories
gave me a lot of pleasure that's what
people tell me now and it's the best
thing any writer can ever hear when
somebody comes over and says I breathe I
derive pleasure from what you've written
I would like to think that everything we
do in our stories helps the readers to
to just understand the world and to have
a little more tolerance and to take the
peaceful and intelligent route instead
of what some people do I've always felt
it would be nice if while enjoying the
adventure if the reader also gets the
feeling that we should all be good to
each other
the world is a small place we only have
a short time in it and we must make it
as pleasant for ourselves and for other
people as we possibly can and doing the
right thing is better than doing the
wrong things behind everything there
should be a good moral tone I've always
tried to put that in they try to do that
now with Marvel and I hope they keep
doing that forever
[Music]
[Music]